organize who is forcing me to give the
last so I'll talk to you today about the
the covering radius and dense lattice
subspaces but what I'll start with is
actually I guess the sort of motivation
for where this these problems kate came
from for me which is in the context of
integer programming and this is going to
to relate to some of the motivation that
Noah mentioned in the first thought of
the week and I'll give you sort of an
impressionistic view of some of the the
tools associated with algorithms for
integer programming that maybe are not
entirely familiar and I'll connect it to
a conjecture of Canaan and lo vas which
would imply faster algorithms for
integer programming and then we will
kind of specialize this to the context
of the Euclidean norm and we will see
that even there there are many
connections to convex geometry and
there'll be connections to this reverse
Minkowski theorem that no one a dead
proved ok so starting from the integer
programming problem for me I'm going to
think of having say some poly tope or
more generally convex body and I want to
decide whether there's an integer point
and usually we will always find such an
integer points out with Mickey in in the
algorithms and a question that's been
open for for a long time is whether
there is a single exponential time
algorithm for this problem such as we
now have for CVP and essentially all of
most of the Euclidean norm problems we
have single exponential time algorithms
but we do not have them for integer
programming and
just the brief very brief algorithmic
history the first algorithm was due to
Hendrik Lenstra who noticed that you
could use basis reduction and tools from
the geometry of numbers and this was
improved by Ravi who gave an end to the
order n time algorithm and apart from
the constant in the exponent these are
the best types of complexities we have
so I'm going to as I said give you sort
of an impressionistic view of the some
of the tools that have been developed to
attack this problem that more or less
will reduce it to getting improvements
not quite two to the end but getting
improvements to a nice geometric
conjecture so roughly speaking at a very
high level the algorithms for solving
the feasibility problem kind of
decomposed into something like a
rounding step where you try and sort of
find the center of your convex body and
round to the nearest integer point and
that you can interpret as some sort of
generalized version of the closest
vector problem and when that doesn't
work you try and break your problem up
into pieces and that's the decomposition
step and the key primitive that is
essentially behind in fact both of these
is going to be like an efficient way of
enumerate in lattice points so I
actually want to start with this because
I'm sure this is something many people
don't know and it's it's useful to have
tools if you need them so this is the
tool that I wanted to mention so here
you have a convex set and you have a
lotta sand just don't worry about how
the convex cities are presented
essentially any way you can possibly
represent the sets usually works and
your
is to compute all the lattice points
inside now if you could do this sort of
efficiently in in you know let's say in
two to the end time then of course you
would immediately solve integer
programming but there are many reasons
why that won't be possible number one
this list could be too big or sort of it
could be empty and you know so you can't
expect to get some sort of complexity
that only depends on the size of the
list so what does the complexity sort of
depend on so if you have the the body
can you have the lattice it turns out
that's a reasonable thing that you can
bound the complexity of enumeration by
is not like the number of lattice points
inside K so in this case it would just
be one but it's actually the number of
lattice points that you see in the worst
shift of K so for example here okay and
maybe morally this might make sense so
if I had my body over here and you could
imagine any sort of interesting way or
smooth way of trying to get at the
lattice points inside here is relatively
likely to start catching the guys on the
outside right and so you know this to
make the measure robust it turns out
that you can measure with respect to the
worst-case number of lattice points the
body can contain and it actually turns
out that this Center is not very
difficult to to compute again we're
happy with to do the order ends flying
everywhere
so if you put K such that its center of
mass is at the origin that's the the X
you you will basically get the quantity
okay so this is something I prove
together with with Chris and my adviser
Santosh Shambala sort of during my my
PhD and let me just give you like a very
brief sense of the kind of tools that go
into this
so here's the body that you want to
enumerate in and essentially the idea is
to use a type of lipslide
so these are ellipsoids that is kind of
roughly the same shape as k and roughly
is basically going to mean that the
number of shifts I need of this
ellipsoid to fully cover K is a single
exponential and the same thing in
Reverse so the number of shifts of this
of K I need to cover this ellipsoid is
also a single exponential sort of the
existence of these ellipsoids was proved
by Millman
I guess hence the suggestive name M
ellipsoids so once you once you know
that after some some works as I was
mentioning a lot of this is very
impressionistic so it's not like I
expect anyone to understand this in
detail just to get the the high level
ideas but if anything seems like super
preposterous you know ask ask away ask
you a question but it's okay so the idea
is you you try and cover the the body
with the shifts of the ellipsoid and
then you enumerate all the points inside
all of the ellipsoids because of this
the shapes being not too far off this
number of points ends up being not too
much bigger than the number of points
that you can get in K in any translation
basically because you're just going to
cover this with copies okay and that's
where you kind of get the bound from but
the interesting question is why is it
easy to enumerate and in ellipsoid and
this is because the Voronoi cell is
amazing so this is sort of taking
inspiration from the the algorithm of or
let's say insights of MU Chen Xuan
vulgaris
so if I make the ellipsoid a ball then
if I have any shift of it it turns out
that if I create this this graph like
exactly the same graph that Matteo was
looking at in the previous talk it turns
out that if I intersect all the all the
points in a ball around any target then
this graph that I get that follows edges
of the Voronoi cell is connected and on
top of it I can actually extract from
this there there are actually more edges
here that I'm not showing there's sort
of this edge for example in this edge
but you can extract from it to tree and
the tree is sort of corresponds to edges
that always move you closer to the
center of the ellipse and so if you if
you can sort of get a handle on this
graph you can do something like
depth-first search or my TS are you here
why matthias coppa told me about a nice
technique called reverse search which
allows you to enumerate all of the
points inside this graph in low space so
anyway so this is why it's actually
useful you to reduce to the case of
enumerated in balls because we have this
amazing structure of the Voronoi cell
and this connectivity structure in
particular ok so so that's the the kind
of hammer like being able to enumerate
lattice points so now let's say we we
want to solve the integer programming
problem so we're going to distinguish
essentially two pictorial cases one is
when the body that you're working with
is very very big and we're going to
measure the size of the body in terms of
its covering radius so the covering
radius is the the smallest scaling of
the body that always contains lattice
points no matter where you shift it or
that if you put a scaled
copy of the body around every lattice
point you will cover all of space so in
in in this context you can see that
roughly speaking no matter where I shift
K it's always going to contain a lattice
point and you can check that you know
the covering radius in this particular
case is sort of two over three and here
if you scale it down anymore
it'll be integer free because the
boundary is the only place you see the
last points okay so here I'm really not
going to say very much except for the
fact that you know intuitively if the
body is very big which actually flips
around with the covering radius because
it means the covering radius is small
then not only does the the body contain
integer points but it contains like deep
integer points and so in essence you can
reduce finding an integer point inside
k2 finding a sort of approximately
closest integer point to the center of K
and this reduces somehow to an
approximate closest vector computation
in in a general norm so so in some sense
in this case we can already solve the
problem in two to the order n time so
we're all good so the issue is the other
case and the other case is when the body
is not fat so we'll say it's flat and
what are we going to do in this case
we're going to decompose the feasible
region now for those of you who have
seen these types of algorithms you have
seen that in the flat case you try and
decompose the region a long integer
hyperplanes
now there is a slightly more general
strategy that you can take which you can
index using essentially this enumeration
tool that I described at the beginning
where in so
so enumerate these these hyperplanes in
this case you can think of that as
taking the sort of projection onto the
y-axis right and you will get if I take
the body and I project it onto the
y-axis I'm going to get these three
points right so I can think of sort of
taking a projection projecting the body
now this projection I should I can think
of it as in this case it's like a 1 by 2
integer matrix but nothing really stops
me from taking larger projections and
what I want to do is I want to recurse
on all of these slices and you can sort
of phrase that in this more general
perspective of saying I want to
enumerate all the kind of the integers
so everything here will get mapped to an
integer because here's an integer here's
an integer so so any integer point
that's in K will get mapped to an
integer through this projection and each
of these projected sort of integer
points will correspond to a sub-problem
that I want to solve so as I was saying
classically we would project onto one
dimension that would correspond to K
equals 1 but more generally you can do
sort of any dimension and you can try
and use the algorithm that I mentioned
at the beginning to actually compute
these subproblems
so what benefit does this give you the
benefit gives you is that it allows you
to apply a sort of a slightly restated
version of a theorem of canola vos which
says that if you're in this fat case
sorry the other case the flat case then
you can find a projection such that it
projects onto some K dimensional space
and the worst case number of lattice
points you see in this in this
projection in any shift of this
projection is essentially 2 to the
k times n to the K so notice that this
grows with K but that's okay because if
I if I kill off if I enumerate this I
kill off k dimensions of the problem and
killing off K dimensions is you know I'm
willing to take more time to do that and
this is basically I'm creating roughly
speaking and subproblems per dimension
is the way and so maybe this is C it
seems like a horrible quantity and in
fact this is not how the original
theorem was stated and instead an easier
and easier quantity you can you can look
at which turns out to be equivalent is
to forget about integer points
altogether and just look at the volume
and roughly speaking the reason why you
don't actually have to care about the
number of integer points directly is
because you know the difficult case is
when the covering radius is exactly 1
okay and when the covering radius is
exactly 1 essentially this this body
will still have large covering radius if
you cover before you will cover after
and the number of lattice points will
always be proportional to volume in
essence if the body is already quite big
then the number of lattice points you
see in it is always roughly speaking
going to be proportional to volume again
if you don't mind single exponential
factors flying around so this is this is
what they they proved and the proof is
actually in in essence an algorithm it
uses some generalized notion of an hkz
basis and if you take it as such you can
actually compute these projections when
you need them and this is what gives you
an essentially an end to the end time
algorithm so that's the smallest
constant in the exponent we currently
know however this so this doesn't you
know
give us any improvement in terms of its
still into the order n where could we
hope to get an improvement so this is
where the conjecture comes in that in
fact this estimate is very far from
being tight and instead of sort of
enumerated like n problems per dimension
you you should be able to find a sparse
projection where the projection
basically tells you that you only need
to enumerate log n problems per
dimension and that's where you there is
hope so assuming this conjecture there
is hope that you can actually get an
algorithm with roughly this complexity
the only star here is that you actually
have to know how to compute the
projection so if you know it exists
you still need to press it and this is
not obvious but that's that's the
conjecture that I want everyone to know
and how can we sort of interpret this in
perhaps a slightly nicer form in terms
of something that looks like a duality
relationship for for the covering radius
so here I've been interpreting it in a
way that's maybe more useful for an
algorithm but now let me show you the
the sort of duality formula that may
look slightly ugly but but sort of gives
you a sense that something interesting
is happening which is the the following
you can sort of normalized values
appropriately and then you can
re-express the conjecture as the
following inequality that the product of
the covering radius times the minimum
normalized volume of any integer
projection should be at most logarithmic
in the dimension and this right hand
side you you will see that this we will
prove this in the context of the
Euclidean norm in a second
but it essentially tells you that
anybody any solution here so any integer
any integer projection here of any rank
actually gives you a lower bound on the
covering radius if you move it to the
other side and we will interpret this in
a second in the in the second half of
the the talk where we're going to sort
of restrict this question to the case of
K being an ellipsoid or more simply in
the case where K is the ball and we're
looking at a general lattice okay so any
questions so far I'm sure it was all
super clear okay okay so now I'm going
to reinterpret everything in a different
light so essentially we're going to
reinterpret this kind of duality
relation as a way to approximate the
covering radius so hopefully we we
believe you know at least we believe now
that the covering radius is sort of an
interesting quantity to study and we're
going to use the this this theory
specialized to the Euclidean case to try
and say more interesting things and in
fact I mean the point of this is that
the correct the specialization of the
Canova's conjecture to the case of l2 is
now proved but it's it was proved by
Noah on oded and we're going to sort of
cover that theory and and see the kind
of connections that it has
okay so lattices I've already talked
about them apparently so the the only
thing I want you to remember is that the
the determinant is is not only the the
volume of a fundamental parallelepiped
but also the volume of any domain the
tile space with respect to the lattice
so in particular that tells me that the
determinant is also equal to the volume
of the Voronoi cell so the l2 covering
radius now that I have a general lattice
I can think of it sort of geometrically
in the following sense
I look at the Voronoi cell and I just
look at the point on the Voronoi cell
that's as far away from the origin as
possible and that's going to be one of
the vertices okay so that's the smallest
ball that contains the Voronoi cell is
the covering radius and so now let's
just talk very briefly about the
complexity of the computational problem
of approximating recovering radius so
what what is the the problem you are
given an approximation factor you're
given the lattice give it given by its
basis and you either want to decide in a
yes instance whether the covering radius
is at most something or in a no instance
whether the covering radius is at least
alpha x that's something and what what
was known about this problem so up to
about let's say 15 years ago so
guruswami daniele and and and and Oded
sort of looked at this problem in in
detail and combining sort of many
different known results as well as some
new results they were able to show this
kind of range of approximation factors
so you you start from
if you if you don't mind to do the N
approximations you can actually
approximate the covering radius in
polynomial time if you don't mind a
routine approximation then there are
certificates both at the covering radius
is large and that it's small so the
covering radius being small you can
basically give a short basis of the
lattice and another very interesting
results is that if you have access to
approver an all-powerful all-powerful
prover you can upper bound the covering
radius up to a factor of two essentially
you you send the prover or random Co set
of the lattice and you ask him to tell
you what the distance of that co set is
from the lattice so he he could he
basically just needs to return a closest
vector to randomly given target and
basically you can convince yourself that
a randomly chosen target is basically a
distance covering radius over to this is
actually quite easy to prove and that
means that you know the the prover will
will will be able to - I mean we'll
always be able to return a point to you
that's a distance less than covering
radius if he wants to and since you
chose a random point it'll very likely
be within a factor two of the covering
radius so this is where the two comes
from so the covering radius is a very
robust property it's Arthur Merlin so
sort of Arthur is is you and you you're
you're asking Merlin who is an
all-powerful prover to convince you that
the covering radius is small so you as
earther will send Merlin a random cosets
at the lattice and he will respond to
you here is the closest point to this
Cosette you know and do with that
information what you will so that's
that's a and so I mean this wasn't I I
think kind of noted at the time
but essentially the Euclidean version of
the canonical vows conjecture at least
if you don't if you let's say interpret
it liberally with poly logarithmic
factors it actually gives you a
certificate that the covering radius is
large that is tight up to a poly
logarithmic factor which would which
from here you can see is an exponential
improvement in the co MP classification
and so what happened since then so this
is sort of really the last few years
so first the the conjecture the kind of
Loess conjecture was actually proved so
this is Odette and Noah
I gave sort of an improved type of
certificate so this is something I will
mention maybe hopefully by the end of
the talk and in fact if you if you are
allowed to use these sort of more
interesting more powerful certificates
then it's highly likely at this point
that you can certify the covering radius
up to a constant factor which i think is
quite surprising which maybe also
illustrates that the covering radius is
somewhat of a magical quantity that you
know deserves lots of study and then
also this AM protocol or at least let's
say the the the guarantee that this am
protocol gives was improved by magazine
of he certainly didn't know what a Ament
but that's what his results implies in
the context of this picture okay so the
yeah I tried to color code it maybe so
the square root of 3 is magazine oh and
then yeah the red is is is me and then
no honor debt is the log to the three
outside it was
the custom yes and that's the easy both
in this one it's more interesting yeah I
mean yeah okay cool okay okay okay
hail to the French yes very cool okay
yes so many people like the covering
movies alright so let's try and say
something about how to interpret this
kind of love us conjecture in in in in
l2 and and the sort of connections
around it so some notation so if I have
a sub lattice of dimension K I'm going
to write nd to be the normalized
determinant so I don't I don't want to
have to normalize by 1 over K everywhere
so I'm just going to write in D for
normalize determinant and if I have a
sub lattice I'm just going to use this
notation to denote projecting L
orthogonal to the span of this okay good
so again we have our covering radius and
I want to get you to how you you you get
to lower bounds based on basically
volumes of projections and this will be
quite simple so I want to lower bound
the covering radius so that we get to
the kind of correct version of Okinawa
love us for this for the l2 norm in the
case of general lattices so what we'll
what we'll do is we'll just start with
the kind of obvious volumetric
comparison so if we start with the ball
of radius covering radius well it
contains the Voronoi cell so it has
larger volume the Voronoi cell is a
tiling domain so the volume is
determinant and now if you kind of
rearrange that expression
and use the fact that volume is
homogeneous to the power n you get this
lower bound and because we know exactly
what the volume of the ball is we can
replace this and note that it is
essentially up to constant factors equal
to square root of n times the normalized
determinant of the lattice so this is
the volumetric lower bound you will get
on the covering radius if you use the
full space however this can be improved
so in this case it won't be because the
lattice is sort of very nice and round
but if your lattice sort of looks like
this
then you can see that the determinants
might become very small because you have
one very dense direction so you should
project it out and if you look at the
lattice and you compare it to it's sort
of projection the covering radius of the
projection will sort of only go down
because projections decrease distances
and now we just apply exactly the same
lower bound on the projection right so
if I apply the lower bound on this on
this projection which is projecting
orthogonal to this particular sub
lattice I get a new lower bound and so I
can now maximize this lower bound over
all sub lattices okay now I mean to be
clear at the end this really only
depends on the span of M but it'll be
somewhat useful to have this formalism
so I can so what I just showed in the
previous slide is that essentially this
is a lower bound for the covering radius
and the canonical VAS question
restricted to l2 is asking for the
reverse inequality so we want to know
how close are these lower bounds to
being tight so you can define what one
can call the kind of l2 canal
constant which says the which gives you
exactly the tightness factor of this
inequality with respect to the worst
case lattice and so some easy
lower bounds on this quantity in fact
you can get them from a very very simple
lattice which is just the appropriate
sort of scaling of Zed N and you can
convince yourself that this quantity has
to be at least square root log of n
right and this is sort of in the spirit
of for many of the conjectures such as
this one and reverse Minkowski the
belief is that the interesting lattices
or the hard cases are you know sort of
the stupid one
and and those are so so in essence you
can conjecture from an intuitive level
that what we're trying to say is the the
in this particular case is that this is
the worst example okay up to you know
small twiddling alright so this is the
l2 Kannamma less conjecture in in in
this case is essentially what you're
doing by doing this is it's essentially
making it so that all of these
determinants which ends up being like
like the the bounds that you would get
from this are basically going to be like
take the projection onto the first K
coordinates and compute this sort of
determinant there and what will happen
is that this term is going to cancel out
with the product of the one over the
square root of eyes to the power 1 over
I we're to the power of 1 over K where K
is the restriction of the
essentially this is exactly going to
cancel out with that so that's what that
does
okay so now I'm going to try and say
something about a tool that I also know
that many of us are not familiar with
which I also wasn't familiar with a few
years ago and is sort of an amazingly
useful concept that is essentially going
to give us a canonical way of
decomposing a lattice into almost
orthogonal blocks and this this tool
well there's first the picture which is
this is called the canonical polygon it
was was it defined by Stuart or earlier
even earlier okay yeah yeah and so first
the picture and then the actual kind of
consequence of the picture so what are
we drawing we're drawing sort of this 2d
plot with the x coordinate being the
dimension of sub lattices and then the y
coordinate we're plotting the sort of
log determinant of sub lattices of that
dimension and we're actually only
interested in the smallest for every
dimension we're really mostly interested
in the sub lattice of that rank or of
that dimension of smallest determinant
which means we only care about the
bottom of this of this curve okay and so
zero zero by the way is so 0 corresponds
to like the trivial lattice you know
that is just the lattice with only the
origin in it and we sort of declare that
it's determinant is 1 so it's log
determinant is 0 at the very end you get
n times log determinant of the lattice
okay and now what we look at is we're
going to look at the lower convex hull
this thing and why is this going to be
kind of an interesting thing to look at
basically because it's going to index
for us a very special chain of lattices
that is called the canonical filtration
so what happens is that if you look at
this lower kumbhak so the vertices of it
have unique lattices that map to them so
there is only one lattice that has this
log determinant of that dimension and
that is l1 and there is only one lattice
that of this dimension that has this
lowest log determinant here that is a
vertex of the of the polygon and that is
l2 and the most amazing thing is that
these lattices actually form a chain so
you will get that this Wow is contained
inside anything in particular inside L 1
and L 1 is contained inside L 2 and so
on and so forth yeah so so this uses
sort of that's a log sub-module arity of
the determinant so like everything is
based on this inequality so if you take
okay I think this is correct if you take
any two sub lattices of L then if you
look at the determinant of M one times
the determinant of M two then it should
be bigger than the determinant of the
intersection times the determinant of
the of the sort of some of these
lattices
is that right now it looks right it
looks right so if you if you take the
log it basically tells you that the the
function log debt over the space of sub
lattices is is submodular and
essentially this is why you get to draw
these lines in essence like you if you
had sort of two lattices that we're here
you could kind of do this and these
would core so if you had two lattices
that went here you would get two other
lattices that would be say here and here
whose average of logs which is
essentially equal to that would be below
this point but and actually so that's
really all you need to prove all of
these properties so it's actually quite
a yes
it's not difficult to prove yeah so it's
there's also why it's a good thing to
know it's not actually very difficult to
work with so good to what what things do
you do you get you get things like I can
tell you what the slopes are so the
slope of this piece is exactly what I
get by taking the log of the normalized
determinants of L to mato one and so on
and so forth and we'll we'll say that a
lot s is is stable or semi stable no
stable no this is semi stable I guess if
the canonical filtration is trivial
which means that the only thing you see
here is the straight line and there are
no vertices in between
yeah so one important thing is that if I
take this canonical filtration then in
terms of the stability concept you can
kind of already see it from the straight
lines here that this block is stable so
every block so L divided by L 2 or L 2
divided by L 1 mata 1 both with all of
those are stable yes yes yes yes I
actually had that picture at some point
and I forgot to put it back in but yes
if you if you take if you take the dual
lattice you have exactly the same
picture but reflected around the around
whatever n over 2 so you know that that
also like tells you that if a lattice is
stable then the polar the dual lattice
is also stable so this stable lattices
or the this canonical filtration is
going to essentially allow us to reduce
like all the analysis associated with
this Kanaan Lovis conjecture to the set
of stable lattices basically the blocks
that you saw before are going to be our
little stable pieces and what's very
important about these blocks is that
essentially if you think about the the
lower bound that you get for the
covering radius because the the if you
restrict to a stable lattice then the
lower bound is trivially maximized on
the full lattice like as in there is no
reason to project and I mean you can
convince yourself of this but it's it's
basically breaking up the latticed into
chunks where on each chunk the kind of
trivial lower bound that you have at the
top level for this for the sequence of
lower bounds you
who cannot love us that is the type one
okay so if you start with a stable
lattice and let's normalize in this case
for the lattice to have determinant one
then the the sort of the only lower
bound you get is is square root of the
dimension right the determinant is one
so square root of the dimension is a
lower bound on the determinant because
the lattice is stable there's no reason
to go to anything else and so this is
essentially you know the Kanaan Lovaas
constant but restricted to stable
lattices
okay and apparently this had sort of
already been studied by by Barak and and
and Shapira or Brock bison and Shapira
and in the context of yet another
conjecture of minkowski's or yes and the
the conjecture in this context which he
mentioned in the open problem session is
that this this content should exactly be
1/2 which is saying nothing else then
the integer lattice is the worst case so
among all stable lattice is the one that
maximizes this constant is the integer
lattice okay so now remark that it's
there's another conjecture that it
didn't mention in the problem session of
lakiya which also applies there's a
another conjecture about covering lady
at local maximum every wave function
very cool so so sort of let's take this
as a as a given for a second and and
sort of look at what what it gives you
so one inequality I didn't write here so
this is a do to sort of know no dead
that and linked these two concepts
together which the first inequality I
just want to write out one line of it on
the on the board in terms of the
derivation it's just the following so if
I look at the covering radius squared
it's actually so here I'm starting with
this canonical filtration which I was
mentioning is the right way of breaking
up a lot of sin two orthogonal blocks
and if I have my canonical filtration if
you know for those of you who are sort
of familiar with the analysis of kind of
Baba's algorithm then maybe it won't be
very difficult to interpret the fact
that if I have broken up the lattice
into into blocks so the blocks are these
Li is mod like Li minus one that I can
kind of trivially upper bound the
covering radius by the sum of the
squared covering radius by the sum of
the squares of the covering radii over
the blocks right so the sum of the
squares of the covering radii over the
books but this is basically ba-bye style
analysis okay so you kind of round to
the nearest lattice point on the on the
lowest block and then you lift it a bit
by bit by bit and the errors are going
to add up in orthogonal subspaces and
each error is going to be upper bounded
by the covering radio
of that block okay so this is just Bob I
this next line is by definition each of
these blocks is stable so just by
definition this is the lower bound or
the upper bound that you get okay and
now if you do a little bit of kind of
algebraic trickery which is some kind of
reverse form of the arithmetic geometric
mean inequality you can get this last
expression and this last expression
turns out to be exactly the kind of
lower bound that you get by projecting
orthogonal to one of the the elements of
the filtration so this right here is a
good Kanaan low loss projection and in
particular what this tells you is that
the Kanaan Lovis constant is at most the
sort of square root of what you have
here which is the square root of log x
what you get for stable lattices okay so
so the whole problem reduces to stable
lattices in like three lines which would
have been very nice to know a few years
ago good so what can you say about
stable lattices so I'm definitely going
over what can you so here are some very
nice links to convex geometry so it
turns out that there are many you know
different characterizations of what
these con or what you can relate these
constants to so one very nice one also
due to Odette inoa is that if you look
at at this like constant for for stable
lattices it can be associated with a
classical constant in the context of
convex geometry which is called the
slicing constant so every convex body
every simple let's say every symmetric
convex
you can associate a number is called the
slicing constant which is basically the
the following number it sort of tells
you that if you scale the body to have
volume 1 and in fact if you apply any
volume preserving transformation you
will always be able to find a slice of
the body that has volume at least 1 over
the slicing constant okay and it's it's
conjectured that for every single convex
body in any single dimension that the
slicing constant is always order 1 this
is a conjecture of board gal and if you
restrict this conjecture to warn my
cells of stable lattices and you look at
the the worst case slicing constants you
get for that this is equivalent to that
number yes well I mean in it's up to its
theta of 1 of that but I mean it's more
precise but I just don't have the time
to be more precise about it you did
indeed yes
yeah so in fact I mean there's a there's
a better way of defining or there's a
very specific way of defining this in
terms of the covariance matrix of the
convex body but I just didn't feel like
going there at this point yes that's why
but data of one so so this is connecting
a sort of very well-known conjecture in
convex geometry to this problem and in
particular if you resolve the slicing
conjecture and then at least up to a
constant you resolve
Barack's conjecture and if you resolve
it strongly then you would exactly
resolve Rx conjecture but I won't get
into that and sort of what else do we
know so these are the kind of this is
where the effective bounds on these on
this constant comes from so this is the
kind of
let's say reverse Mankowski constant
that essentially was introduced by a by
no one the first in the first talk and
the question is how big is this constant
so you take any stable lattice how much
do I have to scale it so that it's
Gaussian Madsen's is less than two so I
conjectured with oded that it was poly
logarithmic in dimension and then Noah
and Oded proved it and in particular if
you want to understand this the the
constant from the previous slide sort of
already if you do apply what was known
from the the tools of bonacic this
constant is bigger than that one okay so
the the slicing constant for Voronoi
cells of stable lattices is that most
the reverse Minkowski constant and so if
you put it all together you get the kind
of poly logarithmic balance that I was
mentioning previously okay so then very
quickly I will try and like mention what
the new stuff is or just a couple of
them and then wall will stop so the
first thing is can you can you do better
for approximating the covering radius in
the sense that we saw that there's so
much structure in this in this question
the Kanaan and Lovaas sort of
certificates look at exactly one
projection and if you look at the sort
of form of the the kind of things we had
before you would wonder if you can get
if you can somehow chain information
together from different projections and
the answer is yes you can so you can
actually show if you start from any
chain of lattices and here I put a
simplifying assumption which isn't quite
needed which tells you that this sort of
you can think of this as something that
is trying to be the canonical filtration
but you're not sure that it is
you look at the kind of slopes of the
filtration that you gets and they should
just be increasing and you get the
following lower bounds starting from any
chain okay and then the important thing
to remember is that if you so looked at
what were dead and and no approved they
essentially proved exactly the same
inequality but in Reverse with this
extra constant okay so in particular if
you plug in the canonical filtration
here you get something that is that is
tight up to a constant that is this
slicing constant of Voronoi cells
basically and that this is a certificate
that you can check in polynomial time so
it tells you that conjectural e up to a
constant factor the covering radius
problem is in Co NT what else can we say
so I won't go into the into the the
proofs of anything you can actually
approach compute these things
approximately I'm not gonna say anything
more about that Jim you can actually
sort of use these ideas to upper bound
the the slicing constant of arbitrary
Voronoi cells not just for annoy cells
of stable lattices so the the theory
allows you quite easily to to kind of
say new things in the context of convex
geometry you also getting back to this
sort of very very original motivation so
this I'm going to spend two seconds on
you can get a very small improvement
conjectural e on the running time for IP
and this is based just on the following
a question or parameter you might you
might say so and this I think is a
fantastic way of sort of exploring
consequences of the canonical of us
conjecture and possibly the the simplest
implication of it that that one can play
around with so what happens is you can
look at the difference in the covering
radius between a body and its symmetries
ation so symmetries ation is you add its
you look at all a minus B where a is and
K and B is in K so the it's a it's a
much bigger body to some extent but the
question is how much bigger and can you
can you upper bound sort of how much the
covering radius is going to drop when
you symmetrize the body and as a
consequence of the canonical of us
conjecture is that if it's true then
this drop can it most be log N and if
that happens to be true so if this drop
is at most log n you get essentially n
to the N over two algorithm for IP which
beats the constant by a factor of two
and so so that's that's it so these are
some open problems and so I learned very
recently from Vika Bartkowski that I
have an alter ego and to help with my
alter egos business as part of an
addition to the cash prize I can also
offer tortillas suburi tow which are so
apparently this is Daniel de douche you
know whole wholesale foods or something
so yeah
this is also I guess my opportunity you
know in case lattices don't work out
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
well we don't we had already alerted
time but there are questions of course
oh yeah it's so my question is you had
this application that you really went
over very quickly about the applications
to convict virtually yeah yeah so so now
you might want wonder weave so the the
connection to the slicing conjecture you
know is only for stable lattices so
Voronoi cells the stable lattices and
you can say okay can we actually prove
something for arbitrary Voronoi cells
and the the answer is yes and
essentially what you can prove is that
any Voronoi cell you can build an
ellipsoid that contains it such that the
ratio of volumes between the Voronoi
cell and the oh I think I think actually
sorry this should have been flipped the
volume of the ellipsoid is at most this
much which is the canonical bus constant
times the volume of the of the Voronoi
cell and this this is basically bounds
what's known as the outer volume ratio
of the Voronoi cell and if you do that
it's well known that you kind of
immediately get the same upper bound on
the slicing constant so that's that's
that's what you get
you know this
[Applause]